montag am montag gehe ich ins kino am
montag backe ich an und kuchen arbeiten
was ich am montag mache arbeiten
montags arbeite ich meistens in dem café
das merkt ein skate halle gehört hier in
berlin am montag fahre ich noch
klosterfest rein thüringen wo ich
arbeite am montag muss ich arbeiten und
versuche aber ganz langsam in die woche
zu kommen und viel an das wochenende zu
denken
dienstag am dienstag habe ich meistens
frei und macht je nachdem worauf ich
lust habe am dienstag arbeite ich am
dienstag durch auch ins kino am dienstag
gehe ich zum sport
[Gelächter]
am dienstag werde ich wieder arbeiten
und vielleicht ein bisschen sport machen
um ein wenig fit zu werden ist immerhin
mitte der woche da muss ich noch ganz
viel energie haben
mit bach mit macht habe ich meine
freunde aber mit wirklich arbeiten am
mittwoch schlafe ich mittwochs abends
habe ich immer ein spanischkurs aber
bisher habe ich noch nicht ganz so viel
gelernt
am mittwoch gehe ich abends mit meinen
freundinnen was essen und was machst und
mittwoch mich freuen dass es schon die
mitte der woche ist und ein bisschen
bergfest feiern und abends vielleicht
ins kino gehen donnerstag
dann arbeite ich auch und abends gehe
ich zu einem skate kurs von einem
vereinen der abends erwachsene in skate
kurs anbietet am donnerstag das weiß ich
noch gar nicht so ganz genau werde ich
wahrscheinlich auch arbeiten aber ich
weiß noch nicht genau an welchem projekt
und wo am donnerstag gehe ich was essen
am donnerstag war es komisch am
donnerstag freue ich mich auf den
freitag gehe ich zum sport am donnerstag
gehe ich zum sport und was machst du
ungelöst
ausruhen energie tanken fürs wochenende
freitag am freitag arbeite ich meistens
auch und dann habe ich wochenende und
treffe mich mit freunden oder
freundinnen und macht was schönes am
freitag treffe ich meine freunde
heute habe ich mich schon nicht mit
meiner frau am freitag bereits ich mich
auf das wochenende fuhr am freitag
verabschiede ich eine meiner
mitarbeiterinnen auf der arbeit und was
man so will
freunde treffen freitagabend freunde
treffen und ein bisschen die woche
ausklingen lassen
samstag samstags entweder arbeit ich
oder wenn ich frei habe gehe ich gerne
auf den flohmarkt zum wochenmarkt und
schlendern am samstag bleibe ich zu
hause umsonst wirklich wieder arbeiten
entspannen also am samstag entspanne ich
häufig sport und was man morgens auf dem
markt geben und vielleicht ein paar
blumen kaufen ein bisschen was leckeres
zu essen kaufen und mich darauf freuen
dass ich abends was kochen kann
sonntag am sonntag mache ich das gleiche
wie am samstag also entweder arbeite ich
im café oder wenn ich frei habe gehe ich
auch auf dem flohmarkt oder setze mich
im café oder ins wasser
zumindest jetzt wenn das wetter so schön
ist am sonntag mache ich einen
spaziergang
sonntag am sonntag entspanne ich auch am
sonntag werde ich mit meinem mann zu
hause
am sonntag ist auf jeden fall das
frühstück der wichtigste moment des
tages da wird ausgiebig gefrühstückt mit
ganz viel leckeren sachen mit ganz
vielen netten menschen und mit viel zeit
jetzt könnt ihr auch selbst noch mal die
wochentage üben in unserer apps elaine
könnt ihr die vokabeln aus dieser
episode vertiefen und eure aussprache
üben klickt einfach mal hier drauf und
probiert ist selber aus außerdem könnt
ihr wie jede woche easy german
unterstützen indem ihr ein patch und von
unserem projekt werde
und ihr könnt auch easy german
abonnieren darüber freuen wir uns
ja und wir sehen uns in ein paar tagen
schon wieder auf diesem kanal schaut
wieder zu